let's look at the headline worksheet for chapter
4 breakthrough advertising and this is
A chapter where Gene gives us a handful
of patterns. We'll more than a handful 38 ways
to strengthen your headline and he he lists
out different different patterns that you
can use for crafting a headline in and
so this is really an exercise of practicing
through through repetit repetition
and challenging yourself to take a
concept take a product. Look at the
pattern pick one in the patterns that the gene talks about in the book
and then see if you can come up with
a headline that fits into
that pattern using your product. So
this could take some some creativity it
may it may be hard for for
one of your products, but maybe not as hard for another but
the only way that you get better at doing this
is through practice so
The idea here and you'll be referring
back to the the book to get
these patterns. So are you gonna do is choose at
least three of the variation patterns
that that are listed on the pages of
breakthrough advertising and here you're just going to name the
pattern you're going to name the product that you are
using it for this exercise and then
you're gonna practice here. So you're gonna
write five headlines for this product using this
pattern that you name and then do it
again. So now you may do the same product. You may do
a different one but then choose a different pattern. So each pattern gives
you the opportunity to practice
a different way to talk about
your your product and talk about your solution. And so
this is just a the goal
here is to get better through repetition and you'll want
to do this, you know more more than just the the three
times that that we've put together here.
You but I think you'll find that. You
know after if you go through all three of these you've you will have
written 15 headlines and in groups
of five where we're using different patterns. It's really
going to get your mind thinking and
kind of stretched in a different way to to
have sort of that that
light bulb that aha moment of maybe a
new way that you can talk about your product and about your
solution to your Market.